yesterday we looked at this bizarre, unhinged
erratic letter that Donald Trump sent to Nancy
Pelosi on the Eve of his impeachment, which
came yesterday.
The letter was truly a joke that couldn't
be further from being presidential.
It looked like a kid wrote it.
It was riddled with exclamation points.
It was filled with lies and distortions and
nonsense.
It made Donald Trump look quite frankly, out
of his mind.
But the clowns at Fox news all day yesterday
were rabidly praising the letter as just out
of this world that was even likened to the
Gettysburg address.
Can you imagine, this should be interesting
because it really illustrates the difference
that I've been pointing to between Donald
Trump and Richard Nixon's impeachment.
Nixon didn't have the benefit of a 24, seven
news cycle that would defend everything he
does no matter what, combined with social
media echo chambers, to then a signal boost,
those absolutely fact free defenses.
So let's go through this.
Let's start with Lou Dobbs, who hosts a total
pro Trump propaganda show on a channel called
Fox business network.
Here's Lou Dobbs.
Speaking of corruption, uh, the radical Dems
and their efforts to overthrow this president,
right?
And it has, uh, the president today wrote
a beautiful letter, a terrific letter to Nancy
Pelosi, which she responded to by saying it
was ridiculous sick.
Uh, in point of fact, it was elegant.
It was comprehensive and it put her and the
radical Dems who have, uh, uh, attack this
president mercilessly for over three years,
uh, precisely where they should be.
Uh, and that is in, uh, in the focus of history
for decades.
Stick out.
Apparently an exclamation point riddled.
Light-filled screed is eloquent to Lou Dobbs
and Lou Dobbs would know about good writing,
right?
I mean, he's a real, uh, he, he's just another
Ernest Hemingway type for sure.
We can go to Lou Dobbs for, uh, opinions about
literature.
Anyway, later Lou Dobbs brings on a guest
who likened to the address, as I mentioned
before, to the Gettysburg who'd liken the
letter to the Gettysburg address.
Take a listen to this
writing a six page letter to Polosi gave her
an opportunity and off ramp if you will, uh,
at the conclusion of that letter.
Uh, and then she responds with a comment to
a reporter with others present saying it was
a ridiculous letter.
Uh, that's her response.
Uh, and, and the ignorance is institutionalized
amongst the, the party of hate.
Now obviously everybody should go read that
letter.
It is a massive, it is the Gettysburg address
of a smear job, false accusations.
What are responses to historical document
Schumer saying we've got to have witnesses.
These folks are living in an alternate reality.
And I don't say that as an insult sometimes
when we say they're in another world, we're
saying it in an insulting way, but it is another
reality.
They have crafted an echo chamber where between
if you watch Fox news and you just have your
social media echo chambers and you repeat
and follow what Donald Trump does, you are
in another reality completely.
This, this seems like the analysis of the
Trump letter that the world is laughing at.
Then income's commentator, Amy Tarkanian who
said that she just loved the letter and she's
thrilled that Trump wrote it.
This is a sickness of this is determined ego.
It is unrelenting hatred,
the American way.
I loved every word of his letter and I'm glad
that he wrote it.
So then that way when, when we do look down
in history, um, back at all the wonderful
things that he was able to accomplish despite
the Democrats' obstruction, I think it was,
um, it was well written and it was definitely
worth it.
Well-written.
There it is again, well-written.
I like what is wrong with these people?
[inaudible] you could say you agree with the
sentiment of the letter, but to call it well-written
is just odd.
Then you had maybe the chief Fox news propagandists
Sean Hannity of course, ecstatic calling it
a powerful scathing beat down of a letter
by Donald Trump because breaking moments ago,
the president while he's fighting back, and
what is a powerful scathing beat down the
president accused speaker Pelosi of declaring
open war on American democracy, would they
partisan impeachment crusade that represents
an unprecedented and unconstitutional abuse
of power by democratic lawmakers.
Powerful, scathing beat down.
Then you had Laura Ingram promote the letter
as Trump teaching Republicans how to fight
and being hard hitting.
Now I read the entire letter.
Uh, it's, it's, it's hard hitting, but a good
friend of mine in Florida was very politically
connected.
Said, the president is teaching Republicans
how to fight like Mitt Romney's rules of order
and we're going to be very old, my dear friend
from New York and we respect you so much,
but I have a slight disagreement equivalent
with you.
Like who am I going to do that?
He's going to take you, come at him with a
club, but he's going to come at you with something
bigger and harder.
And uh, Congressman McClintock
so now understand the propaganda cycle.
Trump sends out the insane letter.
The letter is truly the rantings of a madman.
[inaudible] that's, I don't know how else
to more concisely describe it.
Everybody on Fox news sucks up to Trump, which
is the second round of disinformation and
the propagandizing.
Then Donald Trump tweets about how people
love the letter, which is the third round
of propaganda.
This is what Nixon didn't have in the 1970s
Trump ended up tweeting good marks and reviews
on the letter I sent to Pelosi today.
She is the worst.
No wonder people like her and crying.
Chuck Schumer.
DC has been such a mess for so long and that
includes the previous administration who,
and now we know for sure spied on my campaign,
you know lies of course, and the cycle continues
dragging along the trumpets in this endless
barrage of propaganda and disinformation.
This is why I've been saying for months now
when we speculated about Trump's impeachment,
and early on there was the idea that, you
know, if the Republicans turn against him
in the Senate, maybe he would also resign
like Richard Nixon did.
Richard Nixon didn't.
What Trump has, Trump has Twitter, which for
all its failings does allow him to get directly
into, he's able to inject the propaganda cycle
with energy by tweeting his sick offense in
the media, Fox news, Fox business one, America
news, you know, all these different ones.
They take what Trump starts and turn it into
this is the best thing ever.
This guy's brilliant.
This is so strong.
Everything about this is great.
Trump then says, I'm so pleased that people
are saying that I'm doing good things.
And then meanwhile, because Facebook knows
the type of stuff that you're more likely
to watch, like share or whatever, you exclusively
over time are shown more and more of that
stuff and your filter bubble is simply never
pierced.
This is a major difference from Richard Nixon
in the 1970s I don't know that we have the
ability to say for sure were it not for social
media and Fox news? Trump may have resigned
already in the way that Richard Nixon did.
Trump's a completely different person than
Nixon.
The circumstances are certainly different,
but there's no question that this entire presidency
from the beginning would have gone completely
differently if it did not have the benefit
of 24 hour sycophantic suck up right-wing
news and social media echo chambers, that's
for sure.